knowing that we wanted to tell a story
about Santa Monica and Highland I had
never seen it on in film and TV and I
don't know why I just knew that by
passing this location there were many
stories to be told to hear that I had $2
no I saw that on the bus and a doughnut
it's been four years and a lot has
changed we were shooting at a time where
this area was becoming gentrified now
it's pretty much gentrified altogether
the whole film
really builds up to this climactic
confrontation that takes place with our
entire ensemble cast at what was once
doughnut time and now it's actually
owned by Danny Trejo and he's made it
into trios coffee and doughnuts we
always knew that doughnut time had to be
a part of it it's like honey it was the
hub that many of these girls used at
nights for shelter he didn't want to
fake this at a donut shop on the other
side of town I actually told my
producers if we don't get donut I'm I'm
not interested in making a film a lot
has changed there used to be three
tables and then a side door over here
that's where we had R as Mix wife enter
with the child
we shot over the course of three nights
but only two nights inside and they
started to close at midnight so we can
only really shoot 7:00 to midnight so we
had five hours one night five hours the
second night and it was a running gun
marathon what are you plotting it was
always tight and as you can tell it's
still tight it's a very small space you
know some people think we had a
pimped-out or a tricked-out iPhone
that's not the case we had an adapter
that was literally the size of a
matchbook that fit over the
with a stabilizer and that was that was
it
I was able to move very easily around
and get different angles there were
three iPhones you can see from the
production of this movie we're not
making a ton of life so I had to sell
off one of the iPhones to pay rent okay
but I held on to two of them and one of
them is being donated to the Academy
Museum of Motion Pictures and it's an
incredible honor to have been asked and
we're very very proud very happy
you